So yes, one way to create the index
configuration file is to actually manually edit it.
And another way to get the indexes correct
is to run the queries on local host before
you update the app to appspot. This one here, annotate the property at AutoIndex
is incorrect. I just made this up this at AutoIndex, however
you do have to annotate your properties as @Index,
if you want them to be indexed at all. And actually yes, you don't have
to worry about single property queries because index
are automatically created for ever property that is
marked with at Index. So the only thing you have to worry about for your
single property queries is to make sure that
the property itself has got the @Index annotation.